I want to tell you one story and the
story came from the early 1950s a woman
named Wanda Ruth Lunsford she was a
scientists in New York City and she
published one paper which turned out to
be her only paper in science which
actually pushed that of science what she
did was she took an old rat and a young
rat she put him to sleep and she tied
their skin together so after about a day
or so their blood supply's joined well
several weeks later she looked in that
old rat there were new neurons growing
in the brain the heart beats stronger
and the muscles were bigger the gray
hair turned brown again she claims she
reversed aging people call her Dracula
Frankenstein all kinds of crazy names
well earlier this year three separate
laboratories at Harvard Stanford
University of California San Francisco
repeated the experiment and it worked
and what they showed is at age 25 in you
and I our stem cells go to sleep and get
turned off and proteins from young mice
in this case or young humans can turn
them back on again
and when these stem cells get turned
back on new neurons can be grown repair
happens much quicker into in tissue we
all see red our child breaks his leg he
or she are back walking again a couple
wouldn't even know what happened your
grandmother breaks her leg and it hits
her quality life the rest of her life so
there are clinical trials now using
proteins that were found in young
individuals to try to stimulate bone
repair in the elderly who have fractures
and so just like a diabetic requires a
shot of insulin so that they can manage
their sugar going forward if you break
your leg in the elderly we may just give
you a shot of these proteins to turn
back on your stem cells so you can
repair quicker we're trying it in cancer
because cancer in kids is about 90%
curable once you turn 25 that same
cancer turns incurable so maybe if I can
convince the body it's younger I can
have or we as a science community can
have a bigger impact on cancer so I
leave you with that bit of hope that
aging is something that may be able to
be reversed and not so we can live till
150 but so that we can all live until
our ninth or tenth decade with
there being a decrease in quality in
those last decades because that be the
goal quality years till the end
[Music]